the end of a series of unfortunate
events is finally here and after three
seasons of very fascinating drama
we now have answers to many questions
fans have been dying to know
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video I'm explaining all the
mysteries from the last season of
unfortunate events including the Sugar
Bowl VFD the fate of the Bo dealers and
Count Olaf and who Beatrice really is
keep watching to the end where I reveal
the final episodes secret symbolism and
watch out for the hidden VFD I've snuck
into the video spoilers ahead for the
full series so take care if you're not
up to date one of the biggest mysteries
in the series has been the Sugar Bowl
and why everyone is so obsessed with
getting hold of it
the secrets revealed in the very final
episode when KITT explains to the
bowlers that the bowl simply contains
sugar however it's no ordinary sugar
it's a sugar derived from a botanical
hybrid that VFD developed to defend
against the deadly Medusoid mycelium
which is why during the Opera flashback
after Esme adds sugar from the Sugar
Bowl to Kitts tea she tells her that
she'll find the sugar is extremely
bitter
however kitt never drank the tea sadly
for her given her eventual fate
crucially kiss also reveals to the
Baudelaires on the island that the
hybrid sugar isn't just a cure it
actually immunizes you against the
Medusoid mycelium remember when sunny is
infected with the deadly spores in the
mushroom in the grotto while the
horseradish substitute wasabi that the
Baudelaires used to cure her works but
it's just an antidote not a vaccine and
so sunny gets infected again on the
island in the TV series the Medusoid
mycelium is introduced in season 3
segrin grotto episodes where it's
revealed that gregor and whistle was
cultivating a disease that could
annihilate PFDs enemies the hook-handed
man AKA Fernald warned him that the
weapon he was developing was too
dangerous and risky as it could wipe out
everyone however gregor wouldn't listen
so Fernald burned down the laboratory
which effectively ended up isolating the
mycelium there the botanical hybrid
vaccine in the sugar bowl was recreated
by the bolos parents when they were
stranded on the island the
children discovered this while searching
for a cure after they get infected the
solution lies in a tree their parents
grew which contains the vaccine so when
they eat an apple from the tree they're
cured interestingly the snake that gives
them the Apple in this scene is the same
incredibly deadly Viper from uncle
Montgomery's collection that was falsely
accused by Olaf of killing uncle Monty
by the end of the series the power of
the sugar Bowl's contents is clear
especially if a villain were to have
both that and the biological weapon that
is the Medusoid mycelium the sugar bowl
is also one of the factors that triggers
the schism within VFD in the Opera
flashback Esme and Beatrice argue over
who should keep the valuable sugar
vaccine safe Beatrice knows there are
already tensions within the VFD
organization with some parties arguing
they don't want to put out fires and one
says may about the woman with hair but
no beard and the man with a beard but no
hair but as May insists on keeping the
sugar bowl herself as it completes her
tea set so Beatrice and lemon II
conspire to steal it in their words it's
a wicked thing to do for a noble reason
that phrase in fact is a recurrent theme
throughout the final season as the lies
between right and wrong become blurred
and the bowlers themselves question
whether at times they really acted in a
moral way in fact much of this season
deals with the idea of moral ambiguity
or moral relativism is a personal
philosophy of moral relativism the only
way to survive an ethically complex
world or as an excuse we used to justify
doing bad things
of course Beatrice and lemon ease heist
ends up causing an incident that leads
to a series of unfortunate events when
Esme discovers their plot she faces off
against them but Olaf's father steps in
the wyan ends up dead from a poison dart
that Beatrice intended for Esme Lemony
takes a fall for Beatrice because he's
in love with her and he escapes with the
sugar bowl in a taxi leaving Beatrice
behind and that's why he's on the lam
during the series Olof vows that
Beatrice will burn which gives us the
best evidence yet that he set the fire
that burned down the Baudelaire mansion
killing their parents even though he
later cast doubt on that before he dies
on the island
lemon E's love for Beatrice also
explains why the narrator of the series
is so interested in the fate of her
children and why it's a bittersweet
moment for him when he meets his niece
Beatrice in the final scene the last
part of chapter 14 which serves as an
epilogue to the series takes place many
years later probably at least a decade
after the events on the island in the
epilogue Lemony Snicket comes face to
face with Beatrice Baudelaire the second
she's the daughter that his sister kit
gave birth to on the island and who the
Baudelaires raised there for a year
before setting sail the addition of this
final chapter is a nice nod to the final
book from the unfortunate events series
and as it's the 14th chapter it takes a
story beyond the unlucky number 13
suggesting that the Baudelaires long
streak of bad luck may finally have been
broken we can see that lemon E's niece
Beatrice survived and made it back to
the mainland at some point however the
fact that she doesn't appear to be with
the Bois de leurs any longer suggests
they were separated sometime through the
years in fact there are some interesting
teasers in what young Beatrice tells us
female finished pirates it was after we
sailed away from the island but before
their third trip to briny beach violet
had just tied up her hair to invent the
steering mechanism and Klaus was
studying tidal turns the female finished
pirates that Beatrice mentioned suggests
that after leaving the island on the
boat the children encountered some
Seabourn bandits and the mention is also
a nice Easter Egg to the knot that
violet uses in the second episode of
season 2 this knots called The Devil's
tongue was invented by female finished
pirates in the 15th century the children
evidently survived the pirate encounter
because Beatrice says that that happened
before their third trip to briny beach
that's an interesting detail because in
the original book chapter 14 leaves the
survival of the Bois de leurs unclear
but this implies that they did make it
back to the mainland because in the TV
series we only see the Bois de leurs
visit that beach twice once in the very
first episode where they received the
terrible news from mr. Poe that their
parents have died in a fire and a second
time in the fourth episode of season 3
when the bolars land the Queequeg on
Briony beach where they meet mr. Poe
again although they ignore him and
leaving kits taxi I'd like to think that
the Bois de leurs did make it back alive
even if they did have to contend with a
set of pirates on the way and just maybe
given that violet learns to tie a knot
from them those Finnish pirates actually
ended up helping the bolars on
way back home by the way when the camera
pulls back from the diner for the final
shot of the city notice the ever-present
VFD symbol in the pattern of the
buildings and the streets a little hint
perhaps that the VFD organization lives
on
although Count Olaf really was
absolutely awful to the poor Baudelaires
his deliciously wicked and hilariously
stupid way certainly made him
entertaining to watch and he was
brilliantly played by Neil Patrick
Harris just like kit Snicket Olaf
doesn't make it out in the series alive
however unlike kit in the end olaf died
not from the Medusoid mycelium but from
the harpoon that Ishmael shot into his
stomach a very fascinating detail in
both the Opera flashback and the scene
on the island is that Olaf was actually
in love with kit Snicket this confirms a
suspicion a lot of book readers had and
it also explains some of his
indifference towards his girlfriend Esme
and why he didn't seem that bothered
about breaking up with her remember the
show did hinted Olaf's feelings for Kip
previously for example in season two via
the names carved inside a heart the
other big reveal in the final episode is
that Ishmael is actually the original
founder of VFD he started the secret
organization when he was principal of
Prufrock prep after he spotted talented
pupils with what he calls a gleam in
their eyes for Ishmael the idea behind
VFD was to fight figurative not literal
fires don't like the constantly
reference novel moby-dick were the whale
is both a literal whale and a metaphor
for death the fires at the VFD ends up
involved in turn out to be both literal
and figurative Ishmael says he wanted
the gifted students inside VFD to come
together to stand against the injustice
of this world to make it a quieter safer
place which fits in with the motto we
saw at VFD headquarters the world is
quiet here the problem was that the
organization became divided and split
apart in the schism so ish gave up on
the world and went to live in exile on
the island the supposed paradise that
Ishmael established is like the Garden
of Eden there's even a tree with special
apples on the other side of the island a
clear allusion to the tree of knowledge
and it's forbidden fruit and a snake
also offers an apple to the Baudelaires
just like Adam and Eve Ishmael's
appearance also
traditional ideas of God as a bearded
man with long flowing robes who shields
his people from potential harm Ishmael's
people all have to eat plain food with
no spices or flavors and when the bow
dealers discover dish has been putting
drugs in the coconut cordial he says
there's nothing wrong with a little
opiate for the people which echoes how
Karl Marx dobrze lygian as the opium of
the people a central theme of the show
and books is that many people especially
adults refuse to question authority even
in ludicrous situations like wearing
blindfolds during the trial or failing
to recognize Count Olaf and his crazy
disguises smart characters like the
Baudelaires who read educate themselves
questioned and search for the truth are
contrasted with foolish characters like
mr. poem many others who refuse to see
the reality of what's going on around
them the story plays around with the
idea of ignorance is bliss and does so
in many ways from the theme tunes
refrain of look away to Lemony Snicket's
continued insistence that we stopped
watching this dreadful story and do
something more pleasant instead it's a
clever metaphor for whether it's better
to remain in a state of blissful
ignorance versus a pursuit of knowledge
and advancement ish always recommends
the Islanders discard anything that
washes up on the island for fear that
the object or the technology and
knowledge that it brings might taint the
innocence of the world he's created in
other words caused people to question
his authority and create division
however he's always keen to point out
that he never forces anyone to do
anything and not to mankind's free will
yet the Islanders never do go to the
other end of the island where ish has
been hoarding all the objects for his
own benefit
Ishmael also knows about the special
properties of the apples in the
Arboretum and has been eating them look
carefully when the Medusoid mycelium is
released and you'll notice that ish is
the only person who doesn't start
coughing and choking even though ishmael
knows as a cure in the Arboretum like
many religious authorities he demands
blind faith from the Islanders as he
takes them off on an impossible journey
to reach the horseradish factory on
lousy Lane fortunately for them the
incredibly deadly Viper swims out to
their boat with an apples suggesting
they could have survived and prevented
the disease and spreading to the
mainland
there's so many references packed into
this final episode in the series as a
whole that I'm working on another video
about the show and how it relates to the
books I'll add a card with the link here
and in the video description as soon as
it's ready the finale also delivers a
few more answers about the fates of
other notable characters in the series
the Quagmire triplets survival is
uncertain in the books but chapter 14 of
the TV show tells us that they survived
fire and eagles to be reunited safely
Fiona's fate in the books was also
unclear but in the show we see that both
she and her brother Fernald made it
through and end up reunited with her
stepfather Captain Widow shion's the
survival of the quagmires and
widdershins might also mean that it's
possible violet could rekindle her
romantic connection with one of the
quagmire brothers at some point and
Klaus might also reconnect with Fiona
who he crushed on after meeting her
olaf's troupe who abandoned him after
the white faced woman refused to throw
Sonny off mount brought also get a
pleasant ending in the TV series as we
see they finally get perform on stage
together at least for one night now that
a series of unfortunate events is over
how do you feel about how it ended and
did the show leave any questions and
answered for you let me know your
thoughts and any theories in the
comments below if you enjoyed this then
every week I have new deep dives into TV
shows and movie so hit the subscribe
button and bail to stay up to date with
all my new videos
next up tapleft for a new and fortunate
events video or tap write for another
video you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time you pick
a movie lovers